good morning my name is Keith Grossman
i'm the associate publisher of wired and
it is my pleasure to welcome you all
back to the wired health conference in
partnership with the Robert Wood Johnson
Foundation as we mentioned yesterday and
as you saw yesterday from Rick's Mullen
and Kevin Kelly and Gary wolf and
michael graves and today we're thrilled
to you know provide you with insights
and leading thoughts from some of the
leading minds in science health and
medicine much like yesterday today's
about sparking conversations and
learning not only from our speakers but
from one another so make sure you tweet
you share and you use the hashtag wired
health but before we get started I
wanted to extend our special thanks to
our partners first the Robert Wood
Johnson Foundation who co-created this
concept and whose generosity made this
event possible our premier sponsor IBM
who'll be doing a very special session
today after lunch and our premium
sponsor MD Anderson who recently
announced a 3 billion dollar moonshot to
fight cancer and our exhibitor sponsors
BASF BodyMedia I health and tomorrow
mobile and now it's my pleasure to
introduce my editorial counterpart
Thomas Goetz
thank you thank you and welcome to those
on the live feed at the wired health
conference so spread the word there we
we have not only this room but thousands
out there so so that's an important part
of the community we had this amazing run
this morning that I just wanted we had
we had 20 25 of us got them so you all
got the chance but only only 25 of you
took the bait 22 on a run with the gold
medalist asked needin and we helped
asked instead a couple new records we
got him to do his first run in central
park his his first group run and the
slowest run he's ever done so it was it
was a wonderful wonderful and it was
also the most tracked run I think in
history there were there were 20 people
and probably about 50 tracking devices
so there's seriously they really work
there were there were this guy had three
devices on him born on each wrist and on
his anyway right for okay so so 26
tracking devices so anyway it was it was
great fun yesterday was was incredibly
inspiring i think in a wonderful start
we had Rick Smolin and Gary and Kevin
talking about the power of big data and
the majesty of big data and then we had
this amazing talk by michael graves
where he was you know talking about this
the power small date of the ruler right
the unit of the smallest unit of
measurement we don't even think about it
but the distance you know that a mirror
is from from the ground or the distance
of bed is from a chair those those small
differences are so important i think it
to me it really opened up the the idea
of the power of data to to open up
what's right in front of our eyes
sometimes so i think we're going to
really explore that today and and i'm
ecstatic about it i think the best way
to start is to to introduce John Lumpkin
dr. John Lumpkin the senior vice
president at the Robert Wood Johnson
Foundation he's also the former director
of the Illinois State Department of
Public Health a emergency room physician
and a true leader and a teacher and a
visionary in the science of Public
Health and medicine so please join me in
welcoming dr. John Lumpkin
good morning and welcome this has really
been quite an exciting event and Thomas
thank you so much for the opportunity to
partner in this living by numbers
venture last night was pretty exciting I
think today promises to be equally as
the exciting you know when I was
listening last night I was thinking
about a conversation I had with my dad a
number of years ago when my dad was 39
he had a heart attack and every time he
would go to a doctor afterwards he would
never tell them about it so I said dad
you got to let him know and his response
was you know they're doctors they're
supposed to know now I went to medical
school and one of the things I learned
in medical school was actually how
little doctors do now because they only
see just a small slice of each patient's
life but one of the things I learned in
medical school one of the lessons was
taught to me that if you listen to a
patient long enough they'll tell you
what's wrong with them so caregivers and
patients getting together sharing data
will know so much more about themselves
and that means that people will be able
to make the decisions that are right for
them these are the kinds of innovations
that the Pioneer portfolio at the robert
wood johnson foundation was set up to
support and you know when i look at this
group these kind of ideas for change i
see people who have thinking exciting
thoughts have great ideas and we want
you to share those with us and there's a
number of ways you can do it first talk
to someone who's here from the Pioneer
portfolio and if you are here from the
rabo johnson pioneer portfolio just
stand for a second so people can see you
talk to one of them or tweet us at
pioneer rwjf or connect to our website
at RWJ fo RG backslash pioneer because
together we can make a difference thank
you so much
you